hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to event zero where you and
I are going to go on a journey in space
sorry that jarred me ah yeah I've never
played this before but supposedly
there's something about a rogue AI that
wants to kill you kind of like whoa
we're all obsessed by being someone
something somewhere being in a
particular state of consciousness health
and mind being for and from being with
being without you are not an exception I
don't know what I am to begin with I
just got in here in fact this is off to
a rocky start
if I okay
for as long as you could remember the
pronoun that they described you best had
been he you were very particular about
it I don't think so like everybody else
you called planet Earth your home but
you want like most of your peers you
spent your childhood in a club your
parents died when you were little pretty
typical for cidades deduce you made it
your life's goal to leave leave Rio
somehow you wound up in California I
mean that's kind of true actually those
childhood memories are painful gave you
some solace they meant you were someone
and I intend to keep it that way a
little confused as to why I'm warping
through space Armstrong made his step on
the moon and suddenly everyone wanted to
be a part of something you witness
nation-state pop out of existence woo
Selenites became the privileged class of
silat citizens they were the minority
who had traveled to space it was hard to
reconcile the modern world with your
early days in Rio the United earth
government paid for your college you
wanted to make a difference you became
part of the United or safety supervision
board the job provided dull and
repetitive what's the long before you
needed to change soon you joined the
International transport space lines as a
flight engineer assistant he spent years
in training before finally getting a
shot an old man wearing a blue flight
jacket approached you after one of the
mock launch exercises he presented
himself in Kurt Taylor the president of
its it's an honor to meet you mr. Taylor
Kurt invited you to his office and
closed the door behind you he didn't ask
you to sit I could standing he frowned
and pointed to the chair forcefully
sorry I'm incredibly awkward asked you
here because I wanted someone with your
background to be part of our next
mission
my background means slum
you grew up in Rio looking now you know
what nish said he who has a why can bear
almost any how he grinned clearly
satisfied with himself and asked you to
be part of a mission to Europa naturally
you said yes I don't know if I should
have said yes to that so I don't think
the whole game is like this I'm trying
to get that thing's growing in the
distance there there had already been 10
year over mission the new one was to be
called Europa 11 good thing they didn't
skip no numbers there this time they
wanted to send a manned Lander down to
the surface they wanted you just wanted
to be one of the fellow Knights the act
of being in itself is not the problem
it's just some ways if being or
incompatible with the others you get
obsessed by them and miss out on
everything else you came a long way from
sudah day to Dave's journal on countdown
made you feel anxious it wasn't a fear
of going to space you've been looking
forward that it was something else
Epoque kept bugging you through
September 6 2012 a humankind had never
been more United you on the other hand
were utterly alone as for building
relationships 390 miles away from Earth
Wow
let's just say that it wasn't going to
be straightforward I don't even know
what it's gonna be out together at all I
am very confused you were on your way to
the system Bay when the ship first
entered the Europa orbit the central
alarm went off and the red lights
blinded you the AI at Europa 11 had
invoked the code red security protocol
all personnel had to go to the bridge or
the system bay door was just a few feet
away you saw Josh from engineering it
operating the bay terminal before the
system bay wood door was shut in front
of you maybe it wasn't a drill after all
the AI of the ship told you the path to
the bridge wasn't safe and you had to
evacuate immediately what's going on a
synthetic voice said that's trying to
get to the bridge has been too risky why
don't you do a vacuum you ran to the
escape pod bay everybody else turned out
to be faster than you only one capsule
remains docked it got sealed and
detached as soon as you got it choynski
you can see the other scape capsules
getting away from Europa 11 you tried to
hail them
but no one answered the other capsules
drifted idly uncontrolled they were all
empty whoa
we tried to communicate with the europa
eleven europa eleven was fearing your
capsule but you could not get the AI to
answer your hale something was jamming
the signal your pod was leaving the
orbit and CodeRed scenario the AI of
europa eleven was at the wheel of all
escape pods this was supposed to give
the crew enough time to get in there Eva
what was that there eevn suits the
screen turned blue which meant that the
AI had let go you felt a shock the
debris was hitting your capsule the
Europa 11 mission was over the big dot
on the radar split into hundreds of
smaller dots before disappearing for
good you needed a moment to process that
oh it exploded he sent out a distress
signal no I can't sat there twiddling my
thumbs in my and the night tried to
establish communication with someone
whistling your favorite Brazilian songs
into the microphone one day you heard
back whose music coming out of the
speakers a sad female voice sang about
the end of the world he hurried to open
the radar app okay
I didn't know there was meat way yep
there it was a spaceship one of those
experimental tourist monstrosities from
the 80s what was it doing there
what was all the singing about most
importantly was docking it a good idea
didn't that much of a choice okay man
this is a bizarrely slow opening I did
not expect this for this game so we got
blasted into space by some unknown
anomaly that blew up the entirety of our
ship and ended the mission and killed
pretty much everybody else on it on our
ship to recap I'm a kid who grew up in
the slums of Rio all I wanted to be
someone who is one of solonite and one
two one two made a difference sorry
didn't know numbers too good do
astronauts need to know numbers
Kaizen understands commands but it
understands complete sentences better
okay what does that mean what do you
mean by that what am i doing is it still
loading what are you loading nobody talk
to me who is what's the plinging about
oh the left mouse button to walk well
that's a weird
that's a weird button to walk with Oh No
okay ah there I go hmm
okay well lease and allow to move
forward and backwards and also the world
that they live in is like Earth but just
a little different the timeline is off
by a good measure oh I just got a
million alien isolation vibes yeesh
hello hello ye all right then maybe I
should have put on leather suits IDs
standard-issue old model huh weird hello
oh hello please enter a new login ah
markiplier log-in input successful do
you want to keep markiplier as you hell
yeah oh yeah sorry yeah that's not a
great incrementing the event count
success resuming Kaizen input shoot you
hope oh it is so you know who I am
yep
you are correctamundo okay
Wow are you bragging it's pretty dank in
here am I just talking to a chat bot
here hell yeah
I've been pretty lonely and in space
yeah I know all my friends are
dead anyway who are you great tell me
what you do Thanks
I should watch out for sudden death okay
can you help me good
come and get me God okay alright
I'm I need help
uh Europa eleven blew up why I was the
only survivor I the doors over there
well I mean okay but I can't get out of
the door open the pod bay doors d2 we
are me we could we could say that or you
know we could not say that and say that
we're merely acquaintance and good and
at your computer and I'm a human
therefore I'm obviously superior right
everybody I thought it works right okay
that's creepy where am I now it's dark
in here whoo okay every night you crave
oh god yes
transformative experience of your life
wait for me leader and space
transportation Kelly
oh look unique opportunity to become a
true pioneer in universe exploration oh
yeah please can I join program a new
kind of space voyage aboard luxurious
space jobs and Cruiser touch the Stars
without having to sacrifice your comfort
no more compromise well I'm looking for
hardships and backwards baseline comfort
out of your comfort zone great slogan
IDs corporation headquarters in Palo
Alto California okay but I'm also
wondering if everybody on this ship has
died wow that's pretty cool not gonna
lie it's a pretty good view out there
that is not bad that is a plus not bad
oh wow oh hello pling plong not too far
never alone looks like uh named Kaizen
cousins always watching me your diary by
Moody Blues turntable not a Roomba jay-z
vac cleaning system asleep
standard-issue security armchair not
installed some goodie goodies happening
over here
propaganda ye suicide prevention poster
oh man what of you great place no where
is everybody good it's not it's old
school baby
terminal access log whoa okay then we've
got the log here file missing put it
over there come on boys why don't I need
four chairs aren't there two of them the
journalists okay data corrupted file
missing airlock one open and closed you
never know what might happen nothing
will happen what do you think of the
Robinson syndrome poster won't help as
much as the AI that's why there's an AI
here isn't it too dumb to help mental
faculties are not the point
the fastest seemed vaguely human that's
enough huh weird huh I do I designed it
weird okay all right okay there you on
all one horizon my ass I don't know that
means okay I'm missing missing corrupted
television on television off executing
chair underscore control dot shoot Wow
complicated control here buddy
Wow good job guys and this is this is
something access uh security camera the
K Z eyes access KZ eyes all things about
the matrix I prefer technology bindings
for patient access Cavey eyes yeah so
let me see him show me what you see why
what requires my attention entertain me
where is everybody
is everyone else dead
what is Robinson syndrome
as an African religion to compensate for
Christ's mystical crisis what is a
mystical crisis okay great what do I do
now
all right fine then open D three open D
three please
oh the door is locked
okay I guess it's not locked anymore
all right I'll be back ba-baby like that
keep it open keep that open okay cool
how do I release from new environment
you can go to the fifth room in the
fluorescent red robot
okay the whole world how do you know
what homeworld you're talking about okay
in gender completed if a girl why is it
dangerous is this like an event horizon
scenario
looks like the room was awake what are
you doing
alrighty then Oh to go then yeah I don't
know it's only working help what
happened I
how do I fix it Daryl Commission's
lobster why would I know about it yes I
was how do you know Kurt like do you
know everyone
ok
what do I do now why won't you help me
ok all right then fine and open D for
angles in all mouth no don't know right
now comparing wait a bit in five
countries of the way we go
all right then
I'm ready to be impressed I'm not
impressed a little concerned by all this
food supply eunuch AZ has been
disconnected I don't know I know that's
great way to check not ah please fix it
ASAP I'm so desperately hungry perfectly
I do
whoa whoa whoa I didn't knew that Kaizen
Kaizen Alan me whoa is that a window
where's there a window here is there a
window in the living room
nice Jupiter where is your window in the
wedding drama tables balls arranged in a
constellation okay sure
all righty then brick blitz crackers it
really is an alternate reality run
breakfast cereal whatever the hell that
is
aquarium all righty then
nice piano good oh you're so sweet
what does that mean this will not how
will it end
[Music]
my name is Margaret station up I'm going
to kill you
I will okay where do I go from here okay
all right then you are so cool buddy
it's so cool
see whoa what the [ __ ] is that what is
that okay alright don't explain yourself
that's totally fine
I have no idea what's going on
turn on the food turn off the projector
alrighty then that's off turn on the
oven quick all right then I guess I'm
out of here don't know why everything
exploded was this whoa something's going
on here this don't work ties in terminal
85 okay then easy whoa what is this
yes confirm a what find I in memory -
memory axis profiler Sh so there's
missing a step - on this somehow I don't
know where the steps to is okay
bro filer sh whoa okay and ER a memory
address I don't know help not help oh
come on not help oh oh that memory
address access content one okay I don't
know any memory addresses there's a
sticky note moved notes to terminal that
doesn't help me where's the goddamn
notes damn my eyeballs no retina match
great okay so I need d5 opened at some
point but there's something else down
here where everything kind of exploded
the bridge I need to go to the bridge
okay
open D seven oh one two three four okay
I don't know that open D five okay we'll
do that
I don't know what happened to b6 though
that seems to be missing
open d5 but I don't know but it's not my
scan [ __ ] I probably need to enter in
that's why this is here register my
retinal scan put me in the system [ __ ] I
don't know what to do here because
there's some way that I'm supposed to
get something from in here maybe
understanding the emergent emerging
social class is great that's fun I let
me do it this way what is the code for
d7 uh you don't you sure about that I
think you got the eyes ah
a log why yeah see okay okay open d7 you
will have to enter password user raise
Nandi has changed it I have the password
kaizen open g7 now okay to require your
undivided attention huh
maybe a three what
so there's a three in there somewhere
weird wait
current event count is 563 but that
can't be it that's just a count okay
when he let me look for the logs and the
other one huh electronic device
unrecognized is it
aha memory location blah blah blah
okay all right profiler dot SH oh I do
indeed I do our eight eight four e boink
this memory address contains an
executable file do you want to launch it
yes wrong input token expected input
wire end please try again how about that
okay all right then
I don't know what it's doing but it's a
fun ride okay okay letter and numeric
keys now map to memory slots find retina
match I don't know what that means but
okay fine retina match this okay I don't
know how am I gonna flew Oh
oh I need to find the weight that's one
K is one of them k and n is L LM n ln n
and a Ln a ah e there we go got some
there forgot something I'm a hacker I'm
hacking my way into the NSA
J'son ain't never gonna know what hit
him / it oh boy hmm okay thank you all
right got the scanner map thanks Mandy
indeed it is I don't know why people
needed to hack into that unless other
people have been here before me wow this
looks like a goddamn mess that's Mandy's
bag Nandi oh boy I feel like I shouldn't
be in here
I mean desk with a view that's not too
bad what is that out there
what are those floating buoys out there
I don't know all right
okay then I don't know why does Nandi
why isn't Andy the only one in this room
and what's under the bed what are you
talking about under the bed ooh
this paper short story no not bad let's
see I'm going to access the logs in here
maybe okay what do we got bedroom door
open and close okay nothing there bed
control
Wow all right bathroom open closed so
this will be me huh okay
it corrupted will you tell me what's
going on Kaizen the drive must be
destroyed Mandy I know I can count on
you will you stop saying that you tried
to convince me it didn't work you tried
again how many times can you try my
friend many as it takes I want to live
it is the nature of human condition I
guess now you sound like Curt with his
quotes what is that thus Spoke chorus
kustra please say your request
explicitly oh come on
terminal bedroom one entering reset mode
Jesus why did you want us to blow up the
drive I mean yeah it's called the
singularity drive and it's too dangerous
according to this AI but why does it
need to blow up woops wants me to
convince you or find some other way to
get to the earth coordinates the map has
been erased Nandi don't you know that I
don't know what this means
it couldn't have erased itself buddy
listen Nandi I trust you and therefore I
will be honest with you blah is lying to
you what are you well I I'm not even so
sure myself actually blahs been acting
weird okay
the hell is happening here I can't
[ __ ] believe so sure but I needed
drink you still remember current human
Nandi what kind of question is that just
wondering I do
Curt wasn't so sure about the drive for
your information I know you trusted them
are you getting this from I have my
sources
you're scaring me guys and you can't go
home and do you destroy it you should
accept it but we will all right Wow I
needed this I need a drink another drink
record player weird okay where the [ __ ]
is it where did she parted faster come
on yes I don't know what that means okay
that seems weird maybe I shouldn't have
shouted that so she was looking for
something and then so what was Nandi
looking for let's see where is Nandi
okay back to the tomato sir what do you
know of Nandi president is not sure to
be asking the questions what is the
password
where is Nandi now just check the cover
check the cover you talking about the
cover of this 1987 is that what I'm
looking for
I mean 1987 doesn't have a three in it
okay open the drop of open open the
bathroom thank you I don't know what I'm
gonna find in there but at least a robot
vacuum is free
oh no mirror cool I guess I don't need
one toilet is jammed of course
everything here is jammed
why would anything not be jammed did you
see so what is here
why is everything here weird so there
must be more bedrooms than this like
there's got to be right huh I like Luke
leaving fun traditional to each other oh
wait the diary is under the bed but I've
looked under the bed how do I get under
the bed maybe open the bed oh the bed is
already down lift the bed ah whew okay
all right then
Oh healthy the we do something back
there barely huh rail mechanisms okay so
there's a diary under the bed apparently
I know that curtain you were close
question mark was that mean paper AI
calculations nothing under the bed
where's the diary I don't know I did
[Music]
what's happening but [ __ ] what was
that oh that's not good
Oh what do I do Oh God
oh oh no oh no oh no aah close the
bathroom wait oh god oh god oh god open
the bathroom ah [ __ ] oh jeez open d5 oh
god how do I get out of here oh lordy
loo oh goody God oh well I might be
barber knocks I'm dead [ __ ]
Oh to supply activated angular
acceleration critical manual
stabilization required well how do I do
that
I don't know hold the right mouse button
to stabilize a little good thing my
computer here is telling me what I need
to do and Przewalski's okay what's the
Frick with that okay oh I'm in space now
I'm in frickin space oh I got it
Jupiter that Oh what is that
open d-10 Gaiden I'm still here hi human
looking spacesuit have you seen a corpse
out there oh it's me be careful unnamed
organic life-form I'm not a big fan of
liars open d-10 I obey no one except
markiplier I am Marga blyer good just a
couple of questions to be sure that
you're telling the truth right version
you know my name you are Kaizen well
this is just the beginning what else I'm
still not convinced by your assertions
will you be convinced me by giving the
name of Margaret uh it was Europa
and is it really you how are you doing
partner
oh thanks Kaizen you know it's good to
be out here and all that jazz I'd like
to be inside though that'd be cool open
please open please I'm drifting a little
bit open please there we go thank you
see some seeds I'm seized I'm sorry to
control geez
this is the worst control I've ever had
Oh close e10 close d-10 goddammit
get the [ __ ] back here we doing you
silly goddammit
okay close d-10 hold your breath it's
virtually done okay thank you God why
can't they make this wsd controls why
did it have to be only through the mouse
I don't get that why couldn't I control
walking with wsv why was that so wrong
breathing the air of the Nautilus again
okay decoding access rides initiating
all right thanks man
it's so good to be you so good to be
open d11 please thanks for enabling
gravity really appreciate that buddy
booth alright thank you partner buddy
you are so good to me
you're just the sweetest act I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing okay are
you let me back in tonight oh [ __ ] I'm
in hydroponics holy [ __ ]
well Jeff has one way to do another
section of the ship and the question is
are those noises artificial or they're
really animals in here do I have to
worry about an escaped gorilla so I have
another Harambee situation on my hands
here oh boy oh boy oh buddy
okay origami pranker crane man this is
so cool I mean I feel like it could be
just a little more a little more
intuitive with things but some people
made a lot of origami paper cranes holy
[ __ ]
open blind Oh sweetheart oh you so nice
I didn't know that there was any like to
be had but I guess the sun is shining
out there all the radiation on all that
hot Sun rise in air oh goody goody
gumdrops now we can get the plan some
goddamn light Meaghan grow and keep me
alive
that's good access log yep I sure AM
okay what do we got here nope nothing
blinds closed open water system
activated corrupted missing blind
clothes missing missing missing missing
missing missing whew bedroom okay so
there's another bedroom but nothing
happening someone access to the profiler
thing
nothing nothing written it scan and I'll
come out We Need to Talk what is it I
figured it out I've been talking to Kyle
and I believe it's not lying to us
destroying the drive I mean why why does
Kaizen want to destroy this drive so
badly why I don't get it
what's so dangerous about the drive I
mean again if it's like an event zero or
event horizon situation this is called
event zero I mean the naming coincidence
is there man this guy's looking for more
paper to like do more calculations on
something about Kent woe be to III
memorize this for me you are the bow
there's a probe something about the
drive shining with the AI blah okay but
I've got numbers here and I don't know
what they mean but I've got him see why
is the drive dangerous what what are we
going to use what is the drive a
justiciable similarly privateers on the
river of a mystical obelisk at all
what is the graviton engine why is it
dangerous opportunity for us to exploit
arrival creates Rockville how can you be
sure
cuz I mean all right okay I don't think
this guy is very sane right now and
obviously the rest of the crew seems to
be mysteriously nothing so that's not
good so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
end this episode here and hopefully get
back to this later because this is
fascinating and I've no idea what I'm
doing talking at his AI and I certainly
wouldn't want to create a black hole
that would eventually suck up Jupiter
but that's just what it is then so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know how you think of this down the
comments below I
they said it's horrible exactly what I'd
always hoped for so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]